Hi, I’m Mark L. Mazzeo, director and co-writer
of THE LAST WHITE MAN [now on Kickstarter].
Today I want to talk to you about some DIY
here that we made over the years and how it’s
helped us grow as filmmakers.
So what we’ve built here you can see is
a dolly.
It’s made out of plywood, skateboard wheels
and aluminum angle iron.
A sheet of three-quarter-inch plywood cut
in half and doubled.
For weight it’s big enough for operator
and camera with a tripod that is full footprint
can fit and you put it down here on these
PVC pipe and it will roll along.
So PVC pipe comes in 10-foot lengths.
The dolly is about 4-feet long.
So that means on one 10-foot length, we get
about a 6-foot move.
We decided for SAY SOMETHING we wanted to
buy a second set of pipes.
So we can have 20-feet of PVC pipe which would
give us a 16-foot move.
To connect them, we bought these smaller pieces
of PVC and just taped with some painter’s
tape around the center and that fits nice
and snug into the PVC and you just connect
them.
So this style we found plans for online.
I’m sure you can Google DIY Dolly and find
and find something similar.
The next two designs are things we came up
with on our own.
So these are DIY light panels that we made
for our feature film SOMETHING BETTER COMES
ALONG.
It’s basically just a little piece of scrap
two-by-four, some LED light bars that we bought
at Home Depot.
I think they were less than 10 bucks each
and a little quarter 20 thread that we put
into the bottom so you can put it on a light
stand.
Basically, you turn each light on you can
see that you’re not getting much light out
of these.
But when you’re on location and it’s dark
and you don’t have any access to power,
these really helped us out in those situations.
There are obviously some problems with them
where each individual light bar has a different
color temperature.
To be honest, these days light panels you
can get for pretty cheap on Amazon.
They work really well just as well as expensive
ones.
So this is the kind of thing you wouldn’t
really need anymore.
But if you’re really strapped, it can really
help out.
So this is our latest creation, it’s a car
mount made mostly of scrap wood.
The only thing we bought when we made this
was these threaded rods, nuts and bolts and
these little paint rollers that we use as
pads so we don’t scratch the car.
So what you do is right here we have a two-by-six
and a piece of I believe half-inch plywood.
You can put your tripod head right in there.
You screw it in, tripod head here, camera
on top.
Now I’d recommend if you do something like
this, you want to ratchet strap down, tie
it off, just anything you can do to make sure
your camera is not falling off.
We’ve had pretty good success with this.
We’ve used it on the sizzle reel for THE
LAST WHITE MAN.
You can see the shots of Carl driving his
car.
We’re all done with this and it looks really
good.
You wouldn’t know the difference between
this and a professional hostess rig.
Throughout the years, part of our growth as
filmmakers has evolved using our own ingenuity
to solve problems.
So it’s not about the gear, it’s about
getting the shot you need as cheaply and efficiently
as possible and part of that has been building
this gear when we haven’t had money to buy
or rent anything else.
But it’s also taught us to think outside
the box and to do the best we can with whatever
we have.
And I think that will help us going forward
on THE LAST WHITE MAN [now on Kickstarter]
and any other projects we have.